it breaks my heart to say that two days
before Christmas Dax died suddenly the
news was a gut punch I still can't
believe it and not just because he was
just 37 years old but because Dax was as
full of life as anybody I've ever known
his time on Earth was too short but he
lived like every moment counted ABC
news's Dax Tierra and his wife Veronica
accused of leaving their two kids alone
in the hours leading up to dax's fatal
heart attack last month Veronica now
faces criminal charges and in a
statement on Monday the 33-year-old said
she made a poor decision by leaving
their two-year-old and five-month-old
daughters alone on the night of December
23rd Veronica says when Dax collapsed
she accompanied him in an ambulance to
the hospital asking a close friend and
her parents to go to her children's
hotel room but when they arrived
Veronica says the hotel wouldn't allow
them in and instead called the police
Veronica added that they had two cameras
on the kids while they slept and she
monitored them closely while she was
away from them quote while the girls
were unharmed I realized that it was a
poor decision our family has suffered a
terrible tragedy I respectfully asked
for privacy while my children and I
mourn dax's death
according to multiple reports Veronica
was arrested and booked on two counts of
acting in a manner injurious to a child
just hours after dax's death the couple
allegedly left the girls unattended at
the Yale Club while they went to dinner
with friends at Bobby van Steakhouse
before Dax suffered a heart attack and
While Veronica maintained that she was
monitoring her children closely nypd's
preliminary investigation claims the
girls were left inside the hotel room
for an extended period of time Veronica
is due in Manhattan Criminal Court on
January 12th and ET has reached out to
ABC for comment Dax was passionate about
his work and even more so about his
family
speaking to a group of ABC News
colleagues just last month he noted the
big changes in his life since he started
to work at ABC in my time at ABC I've
gotten married I've had two children One
turns five months tomorrow One turns two
today so I'm gonna bolt out to try to
blow out the candles following his death
ABC News paid tribute to Dax with an
emotional segment pointing out the
executive producer's deep love and care
for his wife and children the love of
dax's life was his wife Veronica and
their two children Sophia and Ella it
was with great pride that Dax brought
Sophia and Ella to this week in
September he was happy living the life
of his dreams Ella and Sophia I want you
to know your father was a great talent
but more importantly he was a good man
and he loved the two of you and your
mother more than anything in the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]